pretty close to fifty of the governor's
and some territory zone and we have a
lot of just about everybody showed up so
that's very nice and we will put them on
the screen as soon as you want thank you
thank you very much Mike you want to say
something Thank You mr. president
Thank You mr. president and I want to I
want to add our thanks not only did the
great team here at the National Response
Coordination Center and and FEMA as FEMA
takes the lead in implementing the
policies that you approved from the
White House coronavirus task force but
as you as you do continually mr.
president I want to thank all the
governor's that are joining us today
today is an opportunity to talk about
the progress that we are making on on
mitigation on testing on supplies we
understand as as FEMA's as FEMA's
mission that this effort through FEMA
will be locally executed state managed
and federally supported and I want all
the governor's to know that we are with
you every step of the way we are
absolutely determined at the president's
direction to make sure that you have the
resources and the support as you see to
the health and well-being of your
communities we commend the governor's at
this point mr. president as we told the
country today three states are 50% of
the coronavirus cases in America today
so we're focusing resources at the point
of the need the governor's in those
states their state health officials are
responding with great professionalism
and great speed we'll continue to
support those that are directly impacted
but by standing up through your national
emergency declaration mr. president
standing up FEMA and standing up the
National Response Coordination Center we
we want our governors we want all of our
state and local health officials to know
that we are as you say bringing the full
full weight of the federal
mental barrier to support our states and
our local communities and that will get
through this coronavirus and we'll get
through this together
I agree with that 100% thank you very
much and for the media
I guess perhaps you're gonna stand aside
and we'll start opening this up okay
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very good thank you very much
and we will consider everything you've
said thank you very much okay who's next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and so Phil try try what you can do the
best you can to get what you can
actually get and we're also having a lot
of things produced that frankly nobody's
ever seen anything like this before but
do the best you can
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is your second request John Bell
what's your second request please the
second request okay we're gonna look at
that and I'm going to try and get you
immediate approval on the hospital I
know about the hospital requested so
we're going to speak to the VA we're
gonna see if we get immediate at least
as the switch but we'll get that
approved for you one way or the other
all right okay thanks a lot John I might
ask very briefly while we're waiting for
the next governor to come on Mike if you
could say a few words and also Debra if
you could say a few words would be great
and then we have another governor teed
up please write again thank you thank
all the governors for your leadership
their partnership in confronting the
coronavirus a few updates and a few
requests for each one of you I want you
all to make your citizens aware the
President signed the family first
coronavirus response act last night
coronavirus testing is free paid sick
leave family leave for caregiver givers
food assistance to the needy get the
word out to your citizens to be very
helpful on
State as we've said many times have
worked with many of you through your
state labs and in certified labs and of
course if the CDC testing is now
available in all 50 states we want you
to be aware that if you have questions
about the availability of testing in
your state you obviously can talk to
your state health department and
healthcare providers but I want every
governor to know that because of the
public-private partnership that the
president forged with our commercial
labs Roche thermo Fisher and as of last
night Abbott Laboratories are now coming
online literally by the hour and when
they are done we will have some 2000
labs stood up around the country with
the high throughput testing your health
care providers will know where those
resources are your State Department will
know where their resources are and we
just encourage you to bring your team
together important to note that that
well now tens of thousands of more tests
are being performed literally every day
the bill the president signed last night
also included a provision that states
and private labs must report all
coronavirus testing results to the CDC
emphasize that dear State Health
Department your health care providers
encourage you maybe to pull them
together today before end of business
we're rapidly expanding testing around
the country but but as dr. Burks will
reflect in a moment we want to make sure
that we're getting the results of that
testing so that we can be informed about
that and of course that the American
people can have full visibility on that
testing as well she'll also explain we
will see as testing is ramping up today
and tomorrow we will see an increased
number of cases we want to give context
to you and to your citizens about that
on supplies President Trump has have
been engaging industry leaders in the
supply chain across the country and to
make sure that personal protective
equipment
and medical supplies are broadly
available on the subject of masks I've
talked to many of the governor's about
n95 masks again in the bill the
president signed last night we have
literally unlocked tens of millions of
n95 masks what the president asked the
Congress to do and they did was we
extended liability protection to all
industrial n95 masks so those can now be
readily sold to your hospitals and
health care providers we urge you to
communicate that to your health care
providers your hospitals today to let
them know that that supply has
dramatically increased and they can
place orders
we also would reiterate if you can reach
out to your construction companies
they're in possession of lots of n95
industrial masks and the president is
urging all those builders and literally
hundreds around the country have already
done this to donate those masks to their
local hospitals and clinics on the
subject of ventilators we are currently
surveying
health care providers around the country
and suppliers and I'm pleased to report
to you that we have already identified
tens of thousands of ventilators
including ventilators that been can be
converted to treat coronavirus patients
your action item on that and your in
your state should be you should survey
your outpatient surgical centers and and
your ORS to identify the type of
respirators that can be converted that
dr. Burks has been working with with
suppliers there's a changed vent that
has to be attached we've identified that
those are available but literally tens
of thousands of ventilators are now
going to be available because of because
of the survey that's currently underway
the other point that we wanted to
emphasize is at the direction of CDC and
the president's coronavirus task force
we are encouraging hospitals
and every American to postpone elective
surgery please explain to your citizens
that this will have a direct impact on
hospital capacity by suspending elective
surgeries it will free up more space in
hospitals including respirators as dr.
Burks explained to me that many people
that require a respirator is because of
a surgery gone wrong and so this frees
up more of our capacity across the board
I know it's not lost on any of the
governor's here mr. president that by
standing up FEMA we you now have
essentially created a structure that
every governor is very familiar with in
dealing with disasters and emergencies
we have activated all emergency support
functions and interagency functions here
Pete Gaynor is here for comments and
questions
we intend to run all of the federal
response in support to States through
here at the National Response
Coordination Center and through FEMA we
this Center is fully operational
governor's I I want you to tell your
teams that this this NRCC will be
connected to your states through your
regional administrators and your State
Emergency Operations centers this will
be very familiar to all of you any
questions that you have the only thing
that I would ask on the president's
behalf if there are issues that arise in
your state begin with your regional FEMA
administrator literally 20,000 people
work for FEMA there you all know what
incredible people they are and they're
ready to go to work to work your issues
so with that mr. president I might just
turn it over to dr. Burks with your
permission and she'll reflect on what we
know about the data and what we know
about the spread of the disease but
thank you for your bold leadership
thanks for what you're all are doing to
implement the president's coronavirus
guidelines it's an honor to be serving
with all of you thank you Mike president
Deborah
mr. vice president you should have
received an analysis of the across the
country Kovach cases analyzed by state
and county to utilizing counties with
more than 50 cases so it's three primary
states of California Washington
California Washington and New York with
the addition counties of New Orleans and
Cook County we are very concerned to
remain concerned in urban areas where
mitigation and social distancing is
absolutely crucial the issue of
decreasing spread due to contaminated
counters and other things in restaurants
and bars as well as movie theaters is
absolutely critical so I know you're
concerned about your hospitals but
critically you need to make sure that
all elective medical and surgical
procedures and dental procedures have
been cancelled that that PPE is being
utilized and transferred to the parts of
your state that need it the most you
look at all elective surgery centers
those are your outpatient surgical
centers and that staff to be your search
capacity those ventilators can be
converted to be utilized the anesthesia
ventilators to be used as ventilators I
think as we all work together to solve
these solutions I think unlocking the
mast and the PPE from construction was
absolutely key as well as as well as
this ventilator situation I think the
federal government has been very
proactive and ensuring that we've
decreased bureaucracy on barriers to
unlock these innovations we believe that
innovations will continue to come from
the field and we appreciate your
frontline workers who have been
informing us about their changes it's
important that we're tracking the data
on a county-by-county as granny early as
we can because we can look at whether
Mitigation is working in those we'll get
feedback from your community this will
only be solved if every single person
and
single community takes responsibility to
ensure that following the presidential
guidelines that were put out several
days ago for the two weeks of stopping
this virus so we will stay in close
communication with all of you through
FEMA we're very excited about the full
activation of FEMA's we'll be able to
provide a dialogue both up and a violent
dialogue down so that we can stay and
close their communication and so we can
ensure that we have prioritized
all stockpile elements based on the
needs and the case structure that has
been reported reporting becomes critical
if we can't see it we don't know how to
unlock the stockpiles so this both test
negative and test positives are going to
be absolutely essential as well as
hospital admissions and CCU beds so that
we understand exactly what is required
from the federal government Thank You
mr. president thank you very much Mike
go ahead Thank You mr. president just
two brief points on the subject of
testing Admiral Gua is with us the US
Public Health Service has built a model
so many of the states have already begun
drive-through testing are doing a
yeoman's work in that space and amber
was here to articulate to you how we can
be supportive of that going forward and
where we're rolling that out last point
the president asked me to emphasize we
want to encourage every governor on this
call to convene your leading health care
providers today to to take inventory of
your medical supply needs and we urge
you to remind them that they need to
look to their supply chains first we'll
prioritize accordingly and any states
that are in the middle of critical
response know that we will work with you
to get you what you need other states
you need to talk to your health care
leaders providers and make sure that
they are going to the supply chain and
we encourage you to to pull them
together today to to emphasize that
point Thank You mr. president
and thank you very much Mike and I want
to get back to the governor's I do want
to say to me
something so big the FDA has approved a
compassionate use for a significant
number of patients we have a drug called
chloroquine a derivation would be
hydroxychloroquine which I hear even
better about it's a common malaria drug
it's been available so therefore the
safety level we understand very well
it's been relatively safe and it showed
very encouraging early results really
encouraging if we if this works as well
as hopefully it might the FDA which
would have taken normally much longer to
do under our great Secretary has been
fed the head of the FDA has been dr. hon
dr. Steven Hogg
he's been fantastic he got it approved
very quickly I won't even tell you how
quickly but let's put it this way it's
approved and we're encouraging you to
take a look at it
we have ordered a lot of it and you can
too it's by prescription it's a very
powerful drug for malaria and also for
various forms of very serious arthritis
but we think it has a very serious very
good impact on what we're talking about
with respect to the virus so you'll take
a look at that and you can coordinate
with us but I think to me that's a game
changer you know about the vaccines are
fine but that will be a while before you
can test them because you have to leave
quite a bit of period we are making
tremendous progress sort of vaccine but
it still takes a long while to test it
we're also studying this and other
promising therapies which is a therapy
produced by Gilead and that would be
REMS it's called REM Nessebar REM
Nessebar and it shows great promise and
red jr. Ron was a company which is also
working very hard on a drug and it's
also they're doing very well they are
the ones that came up with a very
successful solution to evolve
and they've been a fantastic company so
we have some great things but the job
the ones that I mentioned are very good
but especially I think if you look at
the first mention could be a absolute
total game changer and with that I think
we'll go back to the this is my
prescription
but states can issue it and we have it
approved by the FDA and I think it's
going to be something that will be very
interesting to see we're going to know
very quickly but we've had some very
good tests and it's been successful so
let's take a look to me that's probably
the most important thing that anybody
can say if it works but we have it
approved for safety and I want to thank
the FDA for acting so quickly who's
incredible how quickly this was
something that would have taken years
and they got it done
almost immediately based on the past
history of the drug thank you very much
who is the next governor please
I be thank you around PPE I got three
quick things to bring your attention one
is reagents to process the test so once
for example somebody's been swab and we
have a test kit sending it to our lab
we're going to conserve the reagents but
I think some of my colleagues are
actually out so if you can put some
attention in the CDC to make sure we're
okay
that would be our first responders
concern
I've got attorneys in schools our
teachers they can't do anything because
they're sued because of the faint
requirements so if we can have some
temporary guidance will allow us more
flexibility you know our schools again
are operating without students in them
we'd like to be able to use them for
other things and that's good we'll get
right back to you on that Pete thank you
very much great job you're doing thank
you
okay who's next governor who's our next
governor
next
[Music]
so thank you very much well we do like
you going out seeing what you can get if
you can get it faster and price is
always a component of that also and
maybe that's why you lost to the feds
I'll tell you that's probably why but
I'm gonna I'm gonna ask Mike to discuss
that because we have some brand new
information please like well Charlie we
will take that back and appreciate the
feedback
Secretary of HHS is here and we we want
to facilitate all the states and the
health care providers in your states to
be able to access
that supply chain as it becomes more
robust specifically on the defense
production act the the president the
president has has activated the defense
production act but he's not initiated
any other action underneath it right now
what I can tell you is as the president
has brought together leaders of business
and industry and supply chains I think
mr. president you put it well when you
talk about the spirit in American
business about wanting to ramp up
voluntarily to meet the needs that our
health care providers have in this
country is truly inspiring and so the
president has not yet exercise his
authority under the defense production
act he said he will if he needs to but I
think I think the president's perception
the team's perception is now is American
industry is stepping forward very
aggressively and with the changes that
Congress just enacted and the president
signed and we're going to continue to
make to make more and more PPE available
and I will say this too earlier for
everybody the country has really stepped
up like I don't think we've seen it in
many many probably decades it's
incredible the way they've stepped up so
we okay thank you Charlie we're all
facing and thank you so much for joining
vice president pence the former governor
to leave this crisis he's been terrific
and working with all of us and reaching
out to us yesterday we try to
consolidate it down
kind of a group of concerns that that
only governor's agreed on were sort of
our priorities and we talked with dr.
Holzer last night and gave to the White
House those issues some of which you've
already covered already in the
discussion but I just want to walk walk
through them this summarizes the
governor's we're talking about but these
were the ones that were the most there
was the most consensus on one one it was
you know trying to dedicate at least 50%
of the supplemental funding to the
states including some direct funding and
acting quickly on waiver requests you've
done funding the money out faster
[Music]
industries that are being hurt and
getting those checks out for the people
that need them but we have the money in
the states we can really utilize and I
think faster and push it out sort of
like we do and other things with block
grants secondly we've talked about this
a lot but every governor obviously is
trying to work with you and in
bombarding about things about how do we
work together to increase access to PBS
mass test kits extraction kits and
accelerating the production and all of
this life-saving equipment ventilators
and we're working together but that's
obviously something all 50 governors are
at the top of their list third and this
came mostly from your appointees mr.
president the co-chairs of the Council
of Governors Governor Hutchison and
governor EJ about the supporting title
32 authorization to give the governor's
with more flexibility with their
national guards and it helps us pay
those folks and get them benefits that
we've elevated we've activated 2,200
Guard members in our state and this is
nothing I think the governor's advocates
are all tenem your point these are on
this call I believe and providing some
got number four providing some guidance
on implementation of the defense
production Act so we can kind of help
work with secretary a czar and give some
thoughts about how the states could be
more involved
helping that with some of the industries
in our state and lastly allowing us some
more flexibility for the completion of
the census and the Real ID because we're
trying to not force people into like our
MBAs we've waived licensing requirements
so we don't have people trying to get
renewals of licensing and yet Real ID
requires us to get all these people in
there by October 1st there's been
tremendous cooperation you have a
terrific team reiterate what I talked
with the White House about last night
and that is you mentioned it mr. vice
president going through the normal FEMA
process so it's great that you're being
so willing to help governor's personally
but I think things will happen better if
you go through feed your regional FEMA
coordinators and you got more people
addressing these issues but well thank
you Larry you know I think I think the
FEMA is gonna go great we've had so much
we've done so much work with FEMA
unfortunately recently on a on a big
tornado in Tennessee you know that and
then last year on a big tornado in
Alabama and plenty of hurricanes and we
work also in California largely a
California and the big forest fires in
FEMA there's a job like no like no other
and so I think there'll be a tremendous
I know there going to be a tremendous
help on the two points that are relevant
I'd like you to call Steve minuchin I'll
speak to him later
give him a little detail in those two
points please so that while we're doing
this with the center we're getting a lot
of cooperation from Democrats and
Republicans maybe you can make those two
points a little bit with Steve because
few people do agree with that okay thank
you thank you very much Larry thank you
okay next next
mr. president if I die before the next
governor speaks I might with your
permission
Pete Gaynor could give us a couple
minutes I think Governor Hogan
we appreciate your affirmation of the
president's decision to stand up FEMA's
National Coordination Response Center
and and to have all the state requests
and resources funneled through a very
customary system here at FEMA but mr.
president with your permission yes
please like National Response
Coordination Center as the secretary the
Vice President yourself seriously FEMA
is the leading federal operations or was
is leading federal operations on behalf
of the White House corner task force
what we seized the whole of government
response to pandemic like all of you we
are prepared to do this for the long
duration for the long haul
the health and safety of our employees
and the American people is my top
priority as the as of this morning the
HHS crisis action task force and other
federal partners have fully integrated
into the operation space here at FEMA's
National Response Coordination Center
additionally all 10 FEMA regional
response coordination centers around the
country have been activated to support
ongoing response efforts in each of your
respective states and regions
currently there are 50 states of the
District of Columbia five territories of
one tribe that have opted in and have
received the 501 B emergency declaration
of October 19 in support of this FEMA's
primary goal because assure you have the
resources that you need this is what
FEMA needs from everyone
the FEMA regional administrators will
continue to coordinate closely with you
and your team's determine the type and
level support you need as you continue
to respond to this dynamic threat like
all Mercy's responses most successful
one is locally executed state managed
and fairly supported that we cannot
stress this enough at the state level is
informed that your Emergency Management
and public health teams are linked
together
governor's if you have unmet needs
please ensure they have committed to
your respective FEMA regional
administrator they have a direct line
here to the NRCC in Washington DC I
so need your help in emphasizing that at
the local and county level they should
first be following request up through
the state and then from the state to the
FEMA regional administrators again
locally executed state managed and
fairly support recently today we issued
guidance to all states about what
eligible emergency protective measures
are under the Stafford Act so that was
this afternoon and governor's you should
see that shortly we will also be some
guidance on giving more definition about
the defense production act I thank
everyone for the continued partnership
in this effort and as the president vice
president said we will get through this
together as a team
thank you very much Pete and in addition
to FEMA we have the very very talented
man who have dealt with a lot on
building different things throughout the
country the general that you I think for
the most part you know general Thurman
ight and that's the Army Corps of
Engineers and very much involved in a
couple of locations I noticed very
specifically and he's definitely very
busy but he's a good builder and that's
what you need is a good builder so thank
you very much general for being here
okay next governor please
[Music]
yes you are putting together the next
round of stimulus I would ask you please
to consider direct direct and sizable to
our hospitals they're really bearing the
brunt of this the second thing is and I
talked to secretary minuchin yesterday
and we agreed with this I would ask you
to think about the short-term liquidity
needs of state revenue is falling off a
cliff
we we may need to market for kind of
bridge financing to deal with short-term
liquidity
let's do that would be helpful and I
think some of us may need that help in a
matter of weeks not months so I just
wanted to put that on your radar and
then I fully fully supports what has
been asked for as it relates to block
grants because we all of us are on the
ground and need some flexibility to
quickly react to the needs of our small
businesses who you know these guys are
really struggling and we're all going to
have to do our best to help them thank
you thank you
Thank You Gina very much appreciate it
very much and we'll look into all of
those points very strongly thank you
Gary please the states is helpful as we
look at best practices one of the things
I'd like to just suggest is we hear a
lot of what we can't do
there's a lot of gloom out there people
are uncertain they're afraid and we need
to bring some certainty if we can to
when this is good how long we got tread
water here the stock market is in kind
of a freefall and yeah as we look at
least in my state of Utah I think around
the country the economy is still there
are things we can do maybe meeting and
still be able to keep people safe from
the spread of this rather than total
shutdown so I
[Music]
[Music]
but I think you're right 100% and I
think we're going to have a rocket ship
as soon as this thing gets solved as
soon as we beat the invisible enemy it's
an invisible enemy and it's been vicious
it's in over 140 countries if you can
believe that 140 countries so it moves
fast is very contagious but we've really
stepped up at a lot of good things are
going to happen and one of the reasons
we're doing the package is that you're
hearing about reading about and know
about is the fact that we think it's
going to come back really fast I think
we're we're poised to come back very
very fast but we have to get rid of this
and we will get rid of the virus and
hopefully it'll be sooner rather than
later
thank you very much well thank you very
much you're right a hundred percent
we're watching the auto industry very
much we're going to be helping them out
at least a little bit and they've sort
of requested some help and it wasn't
their fault what happened so we'll be
taking care of the auto industry and I
appreciate it very much your comments
thank you our next governor please
governor from Illinois I wanted to first
express my gratitude to your staffs and
to others working in the administration
who we've interacted what they've really
done The Omen work and be responsive to
us and Thank You mr. vice president for
returning calls to us as we needed more
help with the answers to questions about
testing and actually that's why I wanted
to ask a question today we understand
areas drive through testing that's being
stood up across the country we hope to
see it in Illinois will be provided in
Illinois for these drive through testing
okay
these states have done a lot of that
themselves working in conjunction with
us a lot of the drive through has been
done by States but Admiral maybe you
could answer that question please a
couple of numbers for you right now
we're very effectively transitioning to
large-scale testing by leveraging all
components of our American healthcare
system including CDC and state public
health labs healthcare and hospitals and
large commercial labs let me give you a
few numbers between March 2nd and March
14th we made available ten point four
million tests the United States
population we anticipate by March 28th
that number will be twenty seven point
six million tests according to the FDA
so an incredible surge in terms of
supplies which many of you I've worked
with probably about twenty individually
the FDA has made available a number of
options for supplies different swabs
different reagents if you don't have
culture medium you can use sterile
saline saltwater it works good everybody
has that epsilon F da faq website and in
general the commercial market is working
extraordinarily well the CDC and the
public health laboratories to date have
conducted over 45,000 tests and the
clinical laboratories the large clinical
laboratories have now conducted over
63,000 tests of which twenty thousand
were done just yesterday so this shows
the incredible ramp we do not have all
the tens of thousands of hospitals which
ambassador birx is talking about I
wanted to highlight one before I get to
your question that the approval by
Abbott they are Google by the FDA of the
out of the testing system it's very
important to your hospital systems
because it spans a little bit of a gap
between what's done interstate lab and
what's done at the large commercial
laboratories there are about 175 of
these systems throughout the country 150
thousand tests were released yesterday
week these are in 175 of your community
hospitals VA medical centers and they do
about 500 tests per day within your
hospital system now in terms of the
drive through this is the last part we
are standing on 47 sites in 12 states
according to the state needs we asked
through the FEMA regional administrators
for what you needed how we can support
you some states need very little support
some states the significantly more so
far only one week after we started we
will have
several starting today and likely more
than a dozen starting tomorrow and to be
very clear we gave the initial
allocation based on what your state told
us but we want you to work through your
FEMA system we have plenty of tests on
the backside we have plenty of supplies
on the front side work through your FEMA
administrator to give your requirements
and we will bring those back through the
FEMA system to meet them there's been
great demand and a great enthusiasm
among the states for these drive through
centers primarily for health care
workers and we want to support you we
can certainly provide more than 5,000
but we didn't want to give away so much
at the beginning general that shouldn't
be a problem will you please answer that
because everything should be in very
good shape it is absolutely not true
that the drive-through centers are
monopolizing the market we use the swabs
and the swab kits
testing kids we get them to the
commercial market we use a very small
percentage of them when I was asked
about shortages yesterday I went right
to the commercial market got 200,000 and
shipped them to the states that said
they couldn't find them so please look
on the commercial market because they
are there we will help you find them or
we will help you help you to access them
and again
if you send your requirements up and
with a FEMA system we will work with
your states to acquire them or assist
you in any way if we're fully integrated
into FEMA now it's been great and only
twelve hours we've got us all side side
by side so we want to help you we
appreciate the enthusiasm and there will
be more than 5,000 available to you
either the commercial market or we will
assist in fact last night we bought
250,000 swabs and they got distributed
all over - all over the country to the
various states and the states that
needed them the most so JB any problem
call me up but there should be no
problem with that at all thanks a lot
Jeffy thanks Jimmy next governor please
this is 15 ohm from South Dakota Thank
You mr. president mr. vice president for
all your good work we sure appreciate it
I want to tell you a little bit of my
story and I need to understand how your
triaging supplies we for two weeks for
requesting reagents for our public
health lab from CDC who pushed us to
private suppliers who kept canceling
orders on us and we kept making requests
placing orders the morning we would
expect the supply also suddenly did a
cancellation notice because I have the
only well found out that one of my
received reagents when they haven't even
been FDA approved lab and yet so they've
received what I was trying to get for
two weeks and I'm trying to figure out
three ojung supplies that we need
especially when I'm the only lab that
operates on the stage and we were going
through the channels there correctly and
using and searching and asking I'm
probably the one that my other
colleagues were referring to that was
asking for reagents all right we heard
we got you very good
that will never happen to you and it
will never happen to your state governor
will this is secretary this is victory a
czar we absolutely want to make sure you
get what you need there there are many
different reagents that can be used so
after this call we'll get on with you to
help make sure you're getting what you
need at hospital I know how they got
their supplies they probably bought them
on the open market
there's a trillion dollars of open
market supply that's where most entities
are buying this for hospitals buy their
supplies from and states can buy from
but I'd encourage you first please let
your let that need you know your FEMA
regional director so that it goes into
your normal process there but given this
special issue here that is a CDC test
we're gonna get on either team by the
way after this all and we'll get that
issues all parties there is tremendous
supply Deb please and I told them to
prioritize states that have not received
so your hospital I'm not sure what you
mean they're not certified if they have
a spare was this thermo Fisher platform
they are certified to run this assay
da so there will be a lot of commercial
hospitals in your state that will have
access to these commercial laboratories
outside of the CCC trust I understand
about your state local labs and using
your public health labs using the CDC
hace but we're trying to strengthen your
individual hospitals capacity where in
normal assays are performed for your
public Thank You Christie thank you very
much next governor place Thank You
Chrissy next governor please
go ahead go ahead I think we got cut out
next governor please Thank You Mike
we'll take care of that immediately very
quickly all right
next please
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think it's a good idea Pete will do it
through FIBA you so call me
and I needed energy wonderful thank you
very much we'll get it done thank you
very much all right we have let's go
thank you Doug very much thank you okay
next please
like from the bath and I appreciate you
having this call I'd like to ask one big
thing of you I know that you're looking
at potential recovery packages already
in stimulus and I talked about the
airlines and the cruise ships and I
would like you to consider including the
hospitality industry and that I have
unfortunately had to shut down the strip
in Las Vegas and tens of thousands of
hospitality workers displaced as a
result of that and while they're getting
some compensation and filing for
unemployment anything can help we could
get from your in I know but other parts
of the country with a theme park
somewhat non these folks are lower wages
sometimes it would definitely be helpful
if we could include them in any recovery
package I think it's a great idea thank
you very much I think I think it's
something we'll be thinking about it
Thank You governor next please weather
and I might start manufacturing him and
then we've talked about using laser
technology laser training to make the
parts if FDA would give us the standards
and if Congress and the administrator
and the admissions of patent protection
so that we could get into the supply
chain an adequate supply ventilators and
the filters to wear that was one thing
we had to worry about in our supply
chain going forward that would be very
helpful and we can do that too that's
great we can do that easily thank you
thank you bread well ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much it's been
an honor to be with you we'll do this
probably often until this
it's solved feel free to call me the
vice president anybody at the table
anybody in the room except for the media
don't call the media and we will see you
at the next one thank you all very much
thank you
you